[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information locale nous sommes le
mercredi 16 novembre voici les titres
marie-christine le tarnec et la nouvelle
maire de vue en cours elle succède à
françois de ligne et qui avait annoncé
sa démission début octobre toutes les
précisions à suivre dans notre journal
dans notre journal également des images
la réouverture de la médiathèque du
canal à montigny le bretonneux
après 18 mois de travaux et puis vous
découvrirez peps le nom du nouveau site
internet de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines un site internet qui
permet aux particuliers aux entreprises
d'accéder directement à plusieurs
démarches administratives en ligne
c'est donc désormais officiel marie
christine le tarnec a été élu ir maire
socialiste de guyancourt elle succède à
françois de ligne et qui va et qui avait
annoncé sa démission début octobre après
14 ans passés à la tête de la commune
l'élection de l'ex première adjointe aux
finances s'est déroulée devant une salle
du conseil municipal
archi comble les précisions sur des
images de lucile decker 26 voix pour 4
blanc et 2 contres marie-christine le
tarnec est depuis mardi 15 novembre la
nouvelle maire socialiste de guyancourt
l'ancienne élue en charge notamment des
finances succède à françois de ligne et
qu'ils avaient décidé début octobre de
passer le relais après 14 ans à la tête
de la commune ému au moment de prendre
la parole françois de ligne et restera
tout de même conseiller municipal et
communautaire jusqu'en 2020 mes premiers
mots c'est pour dire que j'ai
effectivement beaucoup d'émotion c'est
un passage de relais
un passage de relais qui se passe bien
comme je l'avais dit je reste dans
l'équipe je resterai aussi conseiller
communautaire mais vous le voyez
ma christine mènera le projet de ville
avec une équipe dynamique
je serai jusqu'à 2020 dans cette équipe
et c'est donc avec beaucoup de sérénité
que je peux participer à ces mois qu'ils
sont et ses années qui sont devant nous
pour l'occasion benoît hamon député ps
et catherine tasca sénatrice socialiste
avait fait le déplacement plus d'une
centaine d'habitants également des
habitants que la nouvelle maire a tenu à
rassurer son mandat sera celui de la
continuité
j'ai été élu sur une liste depuis 2014
donc maintenant je suis maire
effectivement au milieu du mandat mais
j'ai participé à la liste de françois de
ligne et on a été élu pour un mandat
effectivement de 6 ans avec un projet de
ville et je vais respecter les
engagements qui ont été pris devant les
aiglons courtois et on va les tenir
l'opposition municipale elle a tenu à
saluer l'engagement de françois de ligne
et durant 14 ans l'élection d'un nouveau
maire signifie également de nouvelles
relations avec la majorité
c'est évident que cette démission doit
aussi nous permettre de relancer de
relancer les échanges de relancer les
discussions avec avec l'exécutif
je proposerai à marketing internet
peut-être de se voir afin de pouvoir
discuter en effet de bien deux des
quatre années qui viendront jusqu'en
2020 marie-christine le tarnec devra
également composer avec quelques remous
au sein de sa majorité municipale les
quatre élus écologistes n'ont ainsi pas
pris part au vote lors de son élection
et cette démission et le choix d'un
nouveau maire pour guyancourt et
forcément un événement politique local
important françois de lignées était le
maire de la ville depuis 2002 écoutez à
ce propos la vie d'habitants de la
commune qui réagissait hier soir à cette
actualité
je trouve que c'est très bien parce
qu'il a toujours dit que thomas hier
c'était son dernier mandat et que
professionnellement c'est à mi mandat
qu'il faut le faire c'est plutôt bien
bien réfléchi bien bien amener bien
pensé je trouve
il a eu une passation de la mare de la
part de monsieur nadeau il fait la même
chose maintenant pourquoi pas je pense
qu'il aurait il là il aurait pu finir
son mandat et puis après appartient quoi
mes moules à démissionner tout d'un coup
gaza
ça fait bizarre en quoi je pensais qu'il
aurait été jusqu'au bout mais pourtant
c'est un symbole mère et je comprends
pas ouais bah ouais c'était un bon ben
ya quoi comme monsieur comme les jeunes
ados étaient avant mais par contre la
nouvelle merde je connais moi ce que
j'attends la nouvelle maire peut-être
deux comment dire ça c'est délicat
par rapport au social par rapport aux
difficultés que peuvent rencontrer les
quartiers qu'il n'y avait pas il ya
quelques temps et on referme cette page
politique avec emmanuel macron qui s'est
déclaré aujourd'hui candidat à la
présidentielle de 2017 l'ex-ministre de
l'économie de françois hollande et
fondateur du mouvement en marche a
notamment déclaré lors d'un déplacement
en banlieue parisienne qu'il souhaitait
à rassembler tous les français
on écoute les réactions la réaction du
représentant à yvelinois du mouvement en
mars très très grande satisfaction parce
que c'est quand même un travail de
longue date que nous avons
minutieusement préparé et qu'il a abouti
qui aboutit d'une très belle façon parce
que je trouvais le discours de ce matin
très juste les mots étaient très forts
au total ce sera 15 grandes mesures qui
sera le socle de des mesures du plan de
transformation qui m'a proposé il qui
sera sous forme de contrat avec les
français pour transformer 2 puis dans le
reste de l'actualité locale la
médiathèque du canal a rouvert ses
portes aujourd'hui au public une
réouverture après 18 mois de travaux d
aménagements ont été apportés avec
notamment l'intégration du musée de la
ville au rez-de-chaussée de
l'établissement
les précisions avec anne laure
l'anguille
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui il ya les muets voilà la
comparaison avec le musée marseillais
paraît certes exagérée
on peut dire cependant que la nouvelle
médiathèque du canal qui a rouvert ses
portes ce matin après 18 mois de travaux
a séduit les premiers visiteurs
ces salles sont chaleureuses les outils
d'emprunt simplifiée et elle bénéficie
d'une nouvelle signalétique tout ce qui
est nouveau aussi c'est la signalétique
qui est totalement refaite et repensé et
qui apporte vraiment un plus par rapport
à ce qui existait avant c'est beaucoup
plus visible avec le rôle les rouges
pour les collections jeunes le gris pour
les collections adultes
au rang des nouveautés un espace réservé
aux ateliers et un coin cocooning pour
les petits de quoi s'évader librement le
rêve de tout responsable de mediatek est
de voir son établissement
fréquenter lisible facile
d'utilisation de voir un public curieux
renouveler intéressés par ce qu'on peut
proposer
l'établissement propose 130 mille
documents à l'emprunt livres bd disent
que revus et dvd un choix qui attire 17
mille visiteurs par mois une ouverture
numérique cette fois ci avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines qui vient de lancer son site
internet peps dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'innovation publique
celui ci permet aux particuliers aux
entreprises depuis le 15 novembre
d'effectuer des démarches en ligne ou de
découvrir par exemple des informations
sur les travaux en cours dans
l'agglomération
reportage d'haussmann vendeurs des le
nouveau service peps accessible à tous a
pour but de permettre aux concitoyens
d'avoir un accès direct aux procédures
administratives comme les demandes de
raccordement de sa maison à
l'assainissement collectif ou encore
l'obtention d'une attestation en vue
d'une vente immobilière
le peps portail espace public service va
permettre aux usagers du territoire
d'avoir leurs démarches facilitées
alors on va l'étendre bien sûr à la
totalité des services mais on a commencé
dans un premier temps par tout ce qui
est concerne les réseaux et réseaux
assainissement et éclairage public
le portail numérique peps s'installe
dans une logique de dématérialisation
des procédures administratives
ça s'inscrit dans le côté innovant de 50
ans des vinyles je rappelle cinquante et
une terre d'innovation mais nous
continuons cette innovation bien sûr
nous avions d'autres sites internet que
tout le monde connaît deux avirons aussi
en ligne
spectacle et billetterie en ligne aussi
tout ce qui concerne les médiathèques
les locations par exemple pour les
étudiants est bien là nous continuons à
développer notre savoir faire technique
pour toucher le maximum de personnes et
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ne compte pas s'arrêter là le
site devrait dans un avenir proche
donner des infos sur la collecte des
ordures ménagères ou encore les travaux
sur la voirie dans les yvelines les 25
centres de protection maternelle et
infantile organise les rencontres
collectives avec les futurs parents
l'objectif est de les aider et de les
accompagner à lapproche d'arrivée de
l'arrivée d'un nouveau né une de ces
réunions se tenait récemment à la pmi de
rambouillet un reportage de maxime le
maine pour le conseil départemental des
yvelines
l'arrivée prochaine d'un bébé peut être
une source d'inquiétude et de
questionnements en quête de conseils
ces futurs parents participaient à une
réunion d'information organisée par la
pmi de rambouillet la rencontre est
animée par une sage-femme et une
puéricultrice
nous on a trop de talent on essaye de se
présenter assez rapidement savoir voilà
si c'est un premier enfant ou
l'accouchement aura lieu s'il ya des
questions vraiment particulière et puis
après ma la parole elle est donnée aux
parents le grand intérêt ces voix-là se
rencontrer parler s'écouter et puis
répondre à toutes les questions qui
n'ont peut-être pas été posée sur un
autre temps qui le temps de la
consultation médicale à tous les
questionnements de ce bébé une fois
qu'il est là je repère les pleurs qu'est
ce que je lui donne à manger comment je
fais les soins le positionnement pour
l'allaitement le l'installation pour le
sommeil et puis ben une fois que j'ai
repris le travail bas quel mode de garde
je peux avoir des questions qu'il est
tout à fait légitime de se poser même
lorsqu'on attend son deuxième enfant
comme c'est le cas dalida chaque course
s est uni dont je peux pas dire que vu
que j'ai eu déjà un enfant que je
connais tous forcément si
ce que c'est que d'avoir un enfant non
forcément là aujourd'hui ça me permet de
renforcer tout ce que moi je connais
déjà
et grâce à cette rencontre de deux
heures maxime et son épouse eux se sont
enrichis de l'expérience dalida j'étais
content qu'il ait une personne qui avait
déjà l'enfant parce que ça m'a permis de
voir en fait mal et comment elle avait
vécu et je trouve que la rocade là bien
être détaillé donc que voit ça me vient
pas en confiance sur ce que je pouvais
attendre de la suite ces rencontres font
partie des centaines d'actions
collectives organisées chaque année par
les pmi yvelinoise accueilli nouveaux
parents atelier massage pour les bébés
ou encore réunions thématiques pour plus
d'informations rendez vous dans votre
pays et mis deux secteurs
il y en a 25 répartis sur tout le
territoire
en sport nouvelle désillusion pour
tanguy de lamotte dans le vendée globe
2016 le versailles et qui visait une
place dans le top 10 sur ce tour du
monde en solitaire et contraint une
nouvelle fois l'abandon après avoir
cassé sa tête de mât samedi au nord du
cap vert
il a tenté de réparer les dégâts durant
deux jours l'yvelinois s'est exprimé sur
sa mésaventure dans une vidéo on regarde
à la séquence donc j'ai pris la décision
difficile avec mon équipe de ne pas
aller affronter les mers du sud avec un
mât dans cet état là et risquent de
s'ouvrir et c'est beaucoup trop
dangereux d'aller dans ces endroits il
reste encore vingt mille milles de
course et j'ai pas envie de risquer le
sur accident donc mon sens marin
veut que je fasse demi tour vers les
sables d'olonne est toujours dans
l'esprit du vendée globe c'est à dire
sans assistance sans escale mais en
solitaire je ramène mon bateau à bon
port
et c'est la meilleur moyen c'est le
meilleur moyen de boucler cette aventure
en boxe le very roi ahmed el moussaoui
26 ans affrontera l'espagnol à ceferino
rodriguez pour le titre vacant de
champion d'europe ebu des poids welters
le combat est programmée le 2 décembre
prochain las palmas aux îles canaries
déjà champion de france et détenteur de
la ceinture de l'union européenne
le saint quentinois sera le favori de la
rencontre même s'il n'aime pas cette
étiquette on l'écoutent que normalement
jugé au dessus du but et après voilà le
sol sinon j'espère en tout cas
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi la rédaction vous donne
rendez vous demain même heure pour une
nouvelle édition bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]